quantum mechanics is supposed to be a
completely general account of the
behavior of the physical world the way
quantum mechanics emerged historically
was that around the end of the 19th
century the beginning of the 20th
century there were more and more reasons
to be worried that the prevailing
classical physics that is the physics of
Newton and later of Maxwell who
incorporated electromagnetic phenomena
into Newton's theory that the Newtonian
maxwellian model of the world that we
had was apparently going to be unable to
account for atomic structure was going
to be unable to account for things as
simple as the stability of matter a
famous a famous problem that that very
much worried people just in the period
immediately before quantum mechanics was
emerged was that people had
experimentally seen that the atom
apparently consisted of a of a small
positively charged core with electrons
rotating around it and it's easy to show
from Maxwell's equations that electrons
circling around going in a circular
orbit around a core like that are going
to produce huge amounts of
electromagnetic radiation they're going
to lose all of the energy of their
orbits to this radiation they should
very quickly crash into the nuclei and
matter should cease to exist so there
was a very acute problem about how
matter could be stable at all the more
this and other related problems were
looked into at the beginning of the
century the more that the less it looked
as if there was any hope at all of an
explanation of these phenomena along the
lines of Newtonian and maxwellian
classical physics it looked like this
was going to call for nothing less
then a global revolution in our
fundamental theories of physics and over
a period of 10 years or so centered on
the period between 1920 and 1930 say a
new fundamental theory of the world was
developed called quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics then aspires to be a
complete replacement for Newtonian
mechanics it now proposes to be
understood as the fundamental laws of
the evolutions of the physical states of
every kind of physical system but as it
as it surely should have quantum
mechanics was engineered in such a way
as to essentially reproduce the
predictions of classical mechanics for
those systems human sized systems
macroscopic and larger systems for which
Newtonian mechanics was known to do a
good job okay and the way it worked out
was that the predictions of quantum
mechanics differed significantly from
those of Newtonian mechanics only for
for very small kinds of physical systems
subatomic systems so on and so forth
which is exactly where we needed it to
differ so it's important to to separate
how the theory was discovered and what
it was what it was originally developed
for from what it proposes to be once
it's there it was originally developed
to account for a new phenomena that we
had discovered at the subatomic level
okay but it was it would be a serious
misunderstanding to interpreted
therefore as merely a specialized theory
of subatomic objects it's supposed to be
the theory of the entire physical world
but its discovery was prompted by
failures of the previously existing
theory in the subatomic realm